another animated film these things are
dominating Rio otherwise known as Angry
Birds the marketing ploy
alright so Rio is the story of a
domesticated blue bird from Rio de
Janeiro who lives is live for this like
nerdy librarian owner but he is one of
two remaining birds of his kind so he
gets flown down to Rio de Janeiro to
pretty much bang a chick lucky son of a
I have been trying to get that gig
for years I'm just saying and the thing
about Blue Bird which his official name
to me is lucky son of a like I
said is that he can't fly he never
learned to fly now first of all yes Rio
is in 3d and does a 3d look good it
looks really really good that's kind of
common at this point if it's a CGI movie
it probably looks pretty good but
there's this one scene where people are
hang gliding and the camera is going
with him and it's going over Rio de
Janeiro I was like I want to hang glide
right there right now cuz where I live
it pretty much looks like so yeah the
scenery in Rio awesome you feel like
you're on vacation for like an hour and
a half now the voice of the main birds
played by Jesse Eisenberg which is
really funny because there's something
about his voice like after I saw the
social network he just sounds like a
douchebag he's not in this movie he's as
normal awkward and nerdy self he's
supposed to be but I'm just saying you
hear him from the social networker in
this movie it's almost like Zach Braff
has dropped off the face of the earth no
one likes his voice anymore he actually
would have been perfect for this role
but Jesse Eisenberg does do a good job
cuz it fits him also and Anne Hathaway
plays the chick bird and you know the
formula after that I mean they meet they
don't like each other and of course
they're gonna fall for each other
because when a girl acts like she
doesn't like a guy that means she does I
don't know how long it's gonna take
before they stop doing that because that
is some stupid tell the truth save
time did I like Rio yes I really did
like Rio and I'm starting to feel soft
like these CGI cartoons are like really
getting to me I like them but they're
good they're a good time and the
characters are really cool too the
characters are actually so good that
George Lopez and Tracy Morgan play a
couple characters in this movie and they
didn't annoy me at all the two people
that annoy me more than anything on
earth so as long as Tracy Morgan plays a
bulldog and George Lopez plays Toucan
Sam they're all right in my book so good
characters are good premise some
excitement some really cool lookin
scenery apologize to your kids for
taking him to hobb go see Rio it's a
really good time you'll all like it I
mean by this time you've seen a lot of
family movies so there's nothing to Rio
that's like really so new even though
you haven't seen a lot of movies about a
flightless bird who finds love and has
to dodge the bad guys so I would say
it's a good time no alcohol required in
fact it's a kid's movies don't drink in
that movie like abusive stepdad
can't leave the bottle down for an hour
and a half seriously does Rio de Janeiro
really look that awesome is it that cool
it always looked like it but I know I
have some subscribers in Rio so let me
know cuz I want to go like I said yes
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]